okay just to finish that up as far as
I'm concerned yes it's impossible to
predict I mean if you think about it who
would have predicted that a high
frequency amplifier would be useful for
eye surgery the high frequency amplifier
was what Charlie Townes was trying to
build when he built the Mesa and that
ended up as the laser and now is used in
eye surgery and also in sort of
supermarket checkout sin barcode
recognition and you name it in lots of
areas of science who would have thought
that doing Radio Astronomy would lead to
an experiment that produced a
breakthrough in organic in organic
chemistry so um my experience is that my
wife has just been wow this is
interesting this is a puzzle let's just
follow it and see where it leads and it
leads to totally unexpected places by
and large and so I that's my science
that's what I see to being better at
than other things and I don't really
have a feeling other than to make some
small breakthrough which interests me
and so I'm not good at answering
foretelling the future but then not many
people are actually yeah okay after you
you have the personal satisfaction of
having won the Nobel Prize what do you
think do you have any other personal
goals
well the Nobel Prize is the big surprise
to me I mean if someone had sent in 1984
before we discovered c60 then I was
going to win the Nobel Prize I said you
know pull the other one because I I know
how good I am as
scientist mo I'm a good scientist but
I'm not a genius and I'd known I owe
some some of my good friends are
fantastically brilliant scientists but I
I'm I'm good good at what I do and have
been very fortunate to have chosen
unknowingly really some very nice topics
and the first thing I was satisfied with
and gave me most satisfaction in sight
in fact more subtle in satisfaction than
c62 discovery of c60 was making the
first carbon phosphorus double bond we
made the phosphorous phosphorous all
keynes and showed how phosphor alkynes
could be made and we did that too using
spectroscopic technique so a lot of
people are not really familiar with that
it was my group that was involved with
that together with John Nixon and a
colleague at Sussex and then the radio
astronomy was really exciting I mean the
most exciting day of my life and
societies was that is when we detected
hc7 and a seven carbon atom molecule on
the radio telescope in our Concord Park
in Canada and of course c60 was
incredibly exciting after we knew
realize what it might be then of course
it has such a paradigm shifting molecule
you know at the end of the 20th century
we discovered the third form of carbon
and molecule been around old since time
immemorial so that was very satisfying
of course then maybe would win the Nobel
Prize
that was seemed a possibility and of
course it's it's it's very nice to win
that award and that is satisfying - it's
a bit odd because I didn't go into
science to win any prizes it was for me
a job and my main passion to some extent
an emotion where I like as interesting
for me and it's graphic art and design
so in a sense I would like to do more of
that but the Nobel Prize has launched
me into other areas where I'm spending
time I'll shoot these questions and I do
a lot of that and I get questions from
people or every day from young people
which I respond to from one or two
people who and I do respond to them
sometimes get a bit irritable because
they ask make somewhat silly comments
but maybe I shouldn't answer them but I
think if I do have something I wanted
ambition its I would like to do some
more art and graphics which is announcer
to one of the previous ones and I I do
still do these graphic arts I mean I've
just done one for art art Sally and it's
basically aliens plants tallahassee aft
and this and the colors of the of the
french flag and that was very satisfying
i get a great kick out of producing a
logo or design that is good and so this
book is very important to me in the
family because it's a sort of family
affair and david's characters which I
put into this fund and my wife and other
son involved in in getting the story to
work as an exciting I think exciting one
but also a scientific to give a feel for
scales as this little boy gets smaller
smaller smaller sigh I'm thinking of
maybe an if that works another book but
I really would like to create something
work of art of some sort which and I
have done some painting which I think
are not bad and they're on my Croton
info size so and I was going to do that
in night when I was in 1985 and then c60
turned up and diverted me for 25 years
away from something I really want
to do and would have been equally
satisfying to me as a person given the
relative molecular scales if the Nano
kids held the world cup tournament would
they be able to use buckyballs to play
or would it end up like the big ball
soccer please see the quirky cartoon
posted on our lenders blog well I
haven't been able to do that well I
think they would and I think c60 does
roll around and it should be possible to
play some form of game with c60 on a
surface and it would be interesting
because it will have sufficiently small
that it might have quantum behavior and
it would be quite interesting to to see
whether one could play quantum football
or quantum American football or in fact
baseball or cricket whether it would
spin in what the spin might be and
basketball with with a c16 molecule I
mean I think it could be possible in the
future I mean we'd have to have improve
our scanning tunneling microscopy you
know atomic force microscopy techniques
but I think that's all because that's
from our Lenna okay I'm an undergraduate
student of chemistry and interested in
research may you please suggest scenario
chemistry which you're currently which
are currently more rewarding for
research I really don't know the answer
to that I'm stepping backwards myself
into trying to understand carbon vapor a
bit better
so I I can't really advise you all I can
say is to tell you what what my
experience was and no general level but
not to actually advise you on a
specifics and when I was a school as I
said earlier I got the book feyza feyza
organic chemistry I've been advice to
get this by my teacher Hera Heaney who
later became a professor of chemistry
and I read that book from carats ago and
I really liked it was written it was it
was written as a bit of a read rather
than just organic chemistry as I if I
had any particular interest it was
organic chemistry when I went to
university and then I discovered I had
lectures from professor Sheffield
spectroscopy and from George Porter on
free free radical chemistry and flash
photolysis and I got pretty excited
about spectroscopy so I got diverted
into something which had a bit of
quantum mechanics and I was interested
in that too and I fell in love with that
subject a bit and then I got the first
degree and pretty good one and I could
go on to do a PhD so I wanted to stay at
university to do the PhD but I wasn't
thinking of becoming a chemist I you
might and particularly I I wanted to
stay at university because I had
was I play tennis for the University and
I was on the art editor for the magazine
I was doing lots of things and they
didn't want to stop I wanted to continue
to do that so I had three years as an
undergraduate in three years as a
graduate student a Sheffield and in fact
became president of athletics Council so
I had a bit of student politics friend
of mine taught me to play the guitar not
very well he taught me very well but I
didn't learn very well but I played a
bit in size how many good timing I had a
girlfriend who became my wife Margaret
sand and solar was I wanted to stay the
nice day to do a PhD and I liked
spectroscopy and with Richard Dickson
who was a spectroscopy I did a PhD and
then home I had offers several offers of
jobs and one was of the BBC to go into
educational television science
television which was interesting and
they were interested but I was already
thinking of going abroad to Canada too
because I want to live abroad to do a
postdoc in spectroscopy which I did and
even then I coming back and getting a
job and then I was asked I went to the
labs to do some more research
spectroscopic research and theory and
then came back to England to a job a
postdoc actually because I had to get
onto the got back and then I was offered
a job in University and so I it was more
than I just followed the things that
interested me at the particular moment
rather than some farsighted aspect so my
advice is whatever situation is at the
present time what is it that turns you
on that you're interested in that you're
passionate about it why is it that you
will always put in a good job never put
in a second-rate job if if you're doing
something where you're happy or
satisfied with a second-rate job don't
do it do something else that you'd be
won't satisfy you all of you satisfies
first-rate work as hard
and you'll find that things will open up
rather than my telling you think of the
moral the physical or the mental
attitude that you have to some of the
things that interest you at the moment
and find if they find them interesting
then maybe they are interesting to you
that's more important than interesting
to other people I found that if it's
interesting to everybody they're already
doing it and they've already done the
exciting stuff I tend to look at things
that interests me personally and follow
those lines with determination that's
perhaps one of the qualities I have I
have a lot of determination I do things
to the best of my ability so no general
area is there something that turns you
personally on follow it through and see
where it leads you Sir Harry kroto
as you said you want people to
understand science how do you think
people from poor countries can get the
education of science and understand it
worked the government of poor countries
should do to make people understand
science well they should get involved in
my Geo set program because that is aimed
at creating this globally accessible
cache of educational material and make
it accessible throughout the world I
mean that's what Google and YouTube and
Wikipedia have done they they have
created this infrastructure that allows
you to in people like when we compare to
really know something to put it on the
web
young people can make a movie and make
it accessible and Google has allowed you
to find it and Microsoft and other
organizations Apple have worked hard on
producing the software and the hardware
to do that so the the infrastructure to
get the educational material to the
teacher is there I still think
teachers very important I mean there
will be kids who can learn by themselves
from the internet but I think the
teacher is there and the key skill the
teacher must have is to be able to
create enthusiasm in young people for
something particularly something for
which they have some particular ability
and encourage that gift that all of us
have something creative and the
infrastructure is there to help the
teachers to do that we can now record
all the great teachers and with we're
starting to do that and what's more I'm
finding with finding that undergraduates
and graduates are very good at creating
educational material and they ferret out
things that are totally unsuspected so
look at my geo set program tell it to
your government people and get involved
and make a contribution to this
Wikipedia is shown that working together
we can create something fantastic
something which far outweighs anything
that any single organization can do I
mean
scientific cyclopdia Britannica it's a
fantastic compendium and 200 years of
work has gone into it but it's not
accessible in the way the Internet is
you as a click of a mouse you can get
moving images but a click of a mouse you
can download educational material that
you can distribute this click of the
mouse you can see a great teacher
teaching this is a paradigm shift for
education and we must really explore
ways and find the best ways of
encouraging governments to put some of
their efforts into this and making a
global network of caches each one in
maybe in universities or teaching
institutions and making it accessible
from everywhere from
South Africa to South America to
Malaysia to India and then perhaps we
will be able to make sure that children
in particular are taught how to
determine what is true and what is
patently not true that's the most
important aspect of Education and
science is the only philosophical
construct that can reliably determine
truth question 23 it cost a lot to
produce foreign are people investing in
way investigating ways semesters it it
actually probably no longer does I think
Mitsubishi Company have a major plant in
Kyushu in South Island of Japan where
they're making large amounts of c60 and
at the moment its application
large-scale is is not great because
we're still trying to understand how to
use it and to some extent we must
realize that today we're an extremely
advanced technological age in which a
huge amount of funding has been put into
certain areas which are have been well
developed a good example would be
computers top-down technology which is
not really nanotechnology all this
small-scale has produced computers and
the camera which is being used here and
the fantastic storage capability of
modern hard disks and flash memories now
that is the culmination of 50 years of
work on silicon based technology to
billions have been spent on it to
develop it to the art that it is at the
present time so if c16 molecules can
replace this by molecular compute
they've got a long way to go a huge
amount of research has got to be put
into it too
for the industry to change over and so
there's a big big inertial barrier to
overcome even if we can do it and it's
it should be possible to produce a
molecular computer which maybe is 10 to
100 times smaller and one dimension may
be 10,000 times smaller in two
dimensions and a million times smaller
in three dimensions but we we don't know
how to do that yet but this should be
possible and but even if we make the
major technical breakthrough in the
development of the chemistry we'll still
have to go through all the other aspects
which are involved so I say you make a
molecular computer which is a thousand
times smaller than the present computer
they may not operate on the same sort of
software does it all I software you
can't you probably won't be able to
transfer it easily I mean the brain it
seems to be some sort of computing
machine but it seems to work a lot
differently from the way that are very
sort of serial machines work we still
don't understand the brain when we do if
when and if we do well we're making a
lot of progress and we'll see that it's
a very clever machine or indeed doing
things in ways that I think modern
computers can't cannot do it probably
cannot do it I don't know so that's the
thing I think Mitsubishi are mass
producing a material and if it's really
going to have a bulk value then I think
it will be come down very very easily
and course they'll be could be a hundred
times cheaper as long there was a
bulking application that's on the cards
but the moment that isn't the case
as a scientists do you see any
relationship between religion and
science what is your stand on the exists
Supreme Being well I'm quite heavily
involved in this question as some of you
might know and I take a sound quite a
rigid stand on it people like Richard
Dawkins and sam Harris Daniel Dennett's
and others who are well known for
speaking out about the science friends
of mine I'll say I said it before but
I'll say it again to this question
science is an arid term it really is it
doesn't it's not understood some people
think it's you know science is just all
this technology around it but no it's
something much deeper than that science
and scientific thinking scientific
method is for me they only philosophic
construct that the human race has
developed to determine what it is
reliably true and what can be true and
what is patently cannot be true and it
depends on evidence it then depends on
questioning and doubting now religion
depends on just the opposite it repent
depends on no doubt and it depends on
belief and in fact Abelar said famous
religious philosopher by doubting we
come to question and by question we
arrive at truth now as everything that
we do in science depends on evidence
what does it mean it means well for
instance I have a four out of five rule
which is if you have a theory and by
that you might some people say a
hypothesis
they're about something then you make an
observation we'll really think of three
or four or five other questions that
need to be answered if you to ensure
that your hypothesis is correct if four
out of five of your experiments work
then you're almost and I say almost
certainly right if only one out of five
fit you're almost and I stress almost
certainly wrong and that was the case
for c60 basically we did several
experiments after we conjectured that it
was a soccer ball and four out of five
or was five out of five all fitted for
instance seventy had to be the second
magic number which it was you could put
something on the inside so it's a cage
and Rick and Bob found that as you made
the case smaller you could put oh yeah
you could only put smaller smaller atoms
in there were lots of little pointers to
indicate that that we were correct and
we were fundamentally proven to be so in
1990 by correction Huffman now I believe
and I say there is a conflict between
science and religion there are some
scientists who say that's not the case
there's no company well there is may not
be a conflict in their mind but there
definitely is a conflict it might
because it's an ethical issue is how do
i how do I convince you that's e60 that
this thing we have a sixty carbonate and
will the mass is 720 that's the evidence
now you go to arena how can I convince
you that religious right and what's the
evidence well there's no evidence
whatsoever and Rossmore which God are we
talking about he talking to the God of
the Hindus or all the gods of the Shinto
is in Japan or the god of the
Supreme Being of the seminoles all the
the rain serpent or the Great Spirit of
the Aborigines of Australia all the gods
of the Aztecs all the numerous other
mystical graves of the Greeks and I
don't think there's any evidence for
this that doesn't mean that religion
isn't important it's important for a lot
of people but I'm not going to discuss
that there is a conflict in my mind
because I need evidence for truth and if
you need evidence for truth religion
doesn't have any it just has belief now
you could say I say I'm an atheist then
some people said well you can't be an
atheist you recite you have to be an
agnostic well okay but what are you
agnostic about I mean you know okay I so
I say okay I'm an agnostic and what does
that mean it means that you can't prove
you can't there's no proof there isn't a
god well alright fair enough but what do
you mean by God what is this concept of
the God that you're talking about and I
can't think I don't I've know no one's
ever come up to me and give me a concept
of a god to be agnostic about so if you
say you're not evil what are you
agnostic about and then the whole thing
falls into things that thought makes
sense just doesn't make sense to me
and things have to make sense I'm a
scientist no it turns out that 92% of
Fellows of the Royal Society or I a
theist freethinkers agnostics less than
10% claim to be religious so when we
talk about scientists let's talk about
scientists and cut off because they're
oh yeah they're good baseball players
and good basket I'm a tennis player I
mean not not as good as I he was so
let's talk about good scientists by some
standards and less safe that was the
Royal Society
members of the National Academy of
Science in the USA Nobel laureates 9 out
of 10 Nobel laureates are atheist
agnostic free thinkers 92% of Fellows of
the Royal Society
atheist agnostic free thinkers and 92%
of fellow members the National Academy
of Sciences are the same so here we have
this problem there's this group of
people the scientists the top scientists
92% of them do not believe in a mystical
Creator now there's a problem because
Congress in the USA
apparently 99% of them claim to be
religious now here's this group of
people a scientific community who by and
large of transformed the world
and they believe something quite
different from the average from a lot of
people and that's where the conflict
lies now there are some scientists who
do believe in God that God and but
they're very small number of good
scientists I mean it's less than 10% so
if we're talking about statistics and I
think that's the case and there is a
very small number and I don't know very
many scientists actually I personally
know very few scientists who I mean they
do know some now that doesn't mean I
don't I'm not aware of the value of
religion to individual people in a
personal level but the conflict is a
serious one in the ethical sense because
if you accept as I do my contention that
science is fundamentally this basically
pare down level about how we determine
what is true then you see there's an
ethical issue in teaching schools and
the netha kalisch you in politics and
everything else now for those scientists
who are religious and to say very few
good scientists and whatever that means
but they cut off the little money I
think they have to have some sort of
intellectual schizophrenia where they
cut off here this is where evidence base
and here's what I believe and I accept
this but the interesting thing is that
by and large of all but by and large
these people believe
in the Gulf they were brought up in well
they just had to rot up in this religion
or that religion and there's an
irrationality which doesn't make sense
and but for many people it's not very
nice to believe that there is no god
there's no afterlife there's no mystical
creator there's no Supreme Being
whatever that means after all you know
what is a Supreme Being I mean you know
I can't even define it so I can't be
agnostic about a Supreme Being that had
no idea how to define it's done the
fluid not nothing you can say can make
sense on this issue and so I'm quite
comfortable with this obviously I think
mm-hmm happy about dying not many people
are and as you get older you becomes a
lot closer of course it'd be nice to
feel that I could you know still be
around looking down and seeing how the
kids were doing but I don't see any
evidence that that's the case and you
know I don't understand it really
because here's this massive business of
religion and churches and mosques all
all based on a reward you know that you
know give us me I'm a big business huge
business huge capital huge assets people
pay money and they've been promised a
reward weathers and there's no evidence
that anyone's ever got it I mean I
sometimes say you know I visited Bernie
Madoff in in you know no I didn't really
but this is anyway went to see Bernie
and and I asked him you know what did
you do it do wrong and but he said you
know Harry I I was stupid I promised
payback in this life
question 25 with the advent of modern
physics okay let me don't have to read
this
analogy with my narrow zone they say
that you know if you after five years in
Tallahassee he will end up with an
allergy due to the these sort of pollen
in the air here question 25 with the
advent of modern physics and the
contradictions to classical physics has
there been any change in chemistry is
there any scope for further change if so
where hmm well here I'm not a physicist
I'm sort of like I don't really fully
understand the contradictions with
classical physics I I mean I think my
feeling is that and I think is true in
the correspondence principle that
classical physics is a an extreme form
of quantum mechanics in the bulk regime
so the knots that must they can't really
be a contradiction I think it's just
that some physics started from things
you could see and do experiments and as
we got rather clever people like Dalton
Dalton and others realize that gases
were made of very small things that we
couldn't see and then we had to
conjecture this and in fact isn't
interesting to think about chemistry
because I think the chemist is really
bit different from many other people
because we do think in terms of this
invisible molecular world an example is
water when I look at a glass of water I
instinctively am still thinking about
the water molecules and the way in which
these interactions occur and that the
bulk effect of this fascinating and
texture of water is a consequence of the
hydrogen bonding behavior in it what it
feels different from acetone and petrol
and and other liquids and so chemists
have this molecular perspective
and I don't know when it when it when I
got it you know it sort of somehow you
sort of they couldn't have always been
there but somehow you glide into this
molecular world and see things in
different way from most other people
even probably physicists and and
biologists and that's interesting so I'm
not sure I'm able to answer that
question between I think the quantum
world and the the classical world I do
know because I'm a spectroscopy that
I've studied the interaction of
radiation with matter and by looking at
the patterns in the spectrum and by
analyzing them we can gently come to a
conclusion about the structure of the
molecule so that the bond lengths of
this length and and I understand the
motion of these things and then but in a
sense it's a bit of an abstract world
and by looking at these spectra and
analyzing the data and coming up with
bond lengths between atoms in molecules
like say thio acid aldehyde one one of
the first molecules we looked at where
we determined the structure you use you
sort of forget that it's a quantum
picture and that you you think of it in
terms of a physical object but you know
that it's oscillating and it has these
models so somehow you are locked into a
classical picture of the molecular world
which is a little bit suspect I think
because that molecular picture doesn't
tell you anything but we know now quite
a lot over the ways in which we take
that very physical ball-and-stick
picture with a pinch of salt and we
understand you know the electrons are
Khanh distributions and when we draw a
stick between our line between a
hydrogen and an oxygen atom it's really
electron density so there isn't much of
a conflict in my mind it's more that we
have a somewhat restricted picture based
on our physical world but we need that
as a framework to hang the quantum
mechanics and the quantum the
mathematics is correct and it's the
mathematics that really is correct more
correct is the language through in which
we understand that world and that's not
easy to explain to other people and that
quantum mechanical picture of the ways
that work it can be very very beautiful
and elegant
in the way that a picture is elegant and
an ask a brilliant architectural design
to solve a bridge problem or whatever is
is beautiful and it's a tragedy perhaps
that so few people don't have sufficient
mathematical fluency to appreciate the
elegance ways in which nature works and
that's the language in which as finally
said nature speaks and that's totally
separated from the most people and in a
sense that's bad for science because
they don't really recognize that there
are passages written by nature which are
as beautiful as that passages
by Shakespeare I know example is as
benzene my wife Margaret said you know
Benzies that thing that smelly thing
people that people think I'll brighten
that's that's what these people think
but in fact benzene is is to organic
chemistry what make Beth is to
Shakespeare or Hamlet sister Shakespeare
and it's a sort of cornerstone its
structure and it was behavior in
aromatic chemistry's this is so
fundamental so elegant and we have some
hand waving mathematics as well involved
and trying to explain why it's such an
important molecule in the whole of
organic chemistry and look living system
chemistry as well so for me it's not so
much a conflict between classical and
quantum mechanics but more important is
the the separation of people who don't
have a good science from mathematical
fluency from an understanding of the way
the world works I mean mobile phones and
based on things like Maxwell's equations
find them began said the most important
breakthrough the 19th century was
Maxwell's equations and he said in
10,000 years time when the Civil War
will be just sort of provincial little
skirmish in the mists of time Maxwell's
equations will still be the key an
important aspect of the way that the
technologies that underpin that world
will work as if we live that long I hope
that will do it was not much of an
answer to your question but it's usually
the case I don't often the answer the
questions I'm asked this probably
because they're doing to understand the
questions and well maybe if they do I
don't know what the answer is so I
usually answer something else sir how do
you define research
that's PV Gotham well researchers per se
what I do basically is a job but it's
intimately bound with puzzled about the
way the world is and how the particular
chemical world in which I'm involved
works and so anything that you do that
you see something that no one else's
looked at and there's something happens
that you find puzzling and then you
disbarred design some more experiments
to try and understand what's happening
that's research and then you can go on
to research and development and say well
how can that research have applications
so research is very much something
derivative from childhood which is the
child has guessing you time wants to
know how how it works and opens it up
and and probably breaks it and can't put
it back together in again but that's
what I did one time I took a toy I got a
Christmas parcel it broke it and my
father took it off me and gave me back a
year later so there you go
there's a bit of a tough going it was
good and but it does require curiosity I
think one problem today is that research
is quite often very expensive and people
want to decide ahead of time whether the
research is worthwhile I mean you know
you have to write a research proposal
and some group of people as some who
really got some don't
breathe his research proposal how to
read and decide whether it's worth
funding and by and large they're wrong
probably most of the time because I
suspect the most important research is
the research that nobody really thinks
is worth doing hasn't been done and
we'll uncover of the unexpected so I
don't know whether that's a definition
but there was there's a definition bound
up in those words somewhere